so with that I'm going
to uh he's known for Sundays are being
apparently leftover omelette day I don't
know why you would wait a week to hit
your leftover omelets but uh ladies and
gentlemen Marl Casa and all of his
fantastic eating all right good morning
everybody how's everybody
doing awesome awesome awesome hey
guys um I have to say
this
I had no idea why the team at D4
actually accepted my submission to a
speaker until yesterday meaning as I
was listening I couldn't be here in
person but I was listening to the uh uh
talks on Zoom through zoom and I
realized that they needed someone that
doesn't understand the topic at all
topic of data as you got to have one at
every conference right so at this one
you got it you're looking at
it meaning my my point with this is to
full disclosure I'm a non-technical
Founder um and I'm looking well we are
working to build a very data
intensive
company um so this is the reason for my
the subject of my Talk data driven
International distribution and the
international distribution will come um
you will understand exactly why the
um take this thing
off does it it doesn't get
off I I was oh my god
really see I said I'm non technical
right I did say
that no good you got it you you totally
got it well I was trying to get this
thing out of the way but I guess this is
there well I don't know well it stays
like that I guess there you go got it
right thank
you you got it so a little
bit um I was born in Angola Southwest
Africa
um as a little kid I remember going
through um with my dad going to some uh
business shows that uh would take
International audiences coming to Angola
bringing Innovation we were living on a
communist um regime back then right so a
little bit of scarcity of a bunch of
stuff right going moving forward fast
forward a few years my early ages I
moved to Europe I studied in Portugal um
funny or not I attended a boarding
school not because I was a bad kid but
actually because he was the best um way
that my my parents found to that we I
could Advance my
education and of course I chose at that
point to study business not not not
nothing related to Tech fast forward a
couple years I moved to the US I went to
uh I graduated from Drex University in
Philadelphia I I worked on Wall Street
as a stock broker so you see me uh uh
everything that I've been doing up until
this point has been business related
when I finished Wall Street I created my
first business which was on
International um U well export actually
of heavy equipment and that was my
introduction to the uh International
distribution play Fast Forward I've
moved away from that industry and I've
been focusing solely on the food and
beverage industry
what I'm working on right now and what
we working on we're working on a B2B
Marketplace that focuses on connecting
emerging food and beverage brands with
International
supermarkets our goal at this well right
now what we're focusing on is helping us
brands that are looking to export their
products into the public the Walmarts of
the world right from the US out and why
am I even interested in that uh on the
subject business of data because
everything that we do touches data from
the very moment
of think of a grocery
store everything here every single item
here is a data reach uh item we collect
uh uh well every grocery store has
average depending on how big they are
between 25 and 50,000 SKS a a grocery
store alone right now multiply that by
every single detail that goes into a um
uh an
item we handle the entire process for
from sourcing the product
all the way up to the grocery shelf
that's what we are looking to build now
and this is exactly how we
started we start by looking at every
single skew and mapping every single po
uh uh point of information that comes
with it attributes is the product uh GMO
free is the product dairy free
um is it
organic put in the put in the
ingredients list is it comes with cocoa
uh
soybeans these are all data points that
will help us do the job that we are
setting ourselves to do as we help
international stores Source Products for
based on their exact need
right even media files right uh uh we
collect information on we have to have a
database of pictures videos of all this
produ of all these products as we are
launching them into our
Marketplace packaging is related to
shipping it's related to knowing exactly
when the single item goes into a box how
many how many items are inside the Box
how big is the box dimensions weight
all of it it's important to
us and of course that even takes I uh
idea or we have to know exactly where do
we got to go pick up this product at
some point where is the manufacturer
because there it has a zip code a
starting zip code right that at some
point will end up going somewhere else
so the other bigest the other important
point that we have to collect is who
actually going to buy this product right
there's a bit there's a database or
there's a um there's a a whole uh chain
of Brands here in the states we know who
they are we know how abundant product is
in in North America I'm covering areas
like in Africa Middle East and pockets
of Latin
America where finding products it's not
as easy as it is here so
who are they who is actually who is
actually uh uh uh on my on my Supply who
are the manufacturers in the US that
these products can access are they new
are they small meaning uh what is their
ability to deliver a big order versus a
small order it it that that impacts
who's going to look into them who may
not look into them yet at some point
meaning a Public's when you get into a
public
uh uh you get access to 20 let's say 100
stores in this in the Florida region
versus if you just get into a um um Mom
and Pop Shop you only have one of small
locations will the will the
manufacturers have the ability to
deliver that we don't know that so
that's part of what the supply I'm sorry
the demand doesn't know that so that's
what we have to uh bundle into our
database that's all uh um information
that we collect what products do they
actually have is it one item is it two
is it a whole array of 10 different SKS
20 different SKS 100 different SKS all
that affects the size of the order that
a supermarket made place with that
individual brand right or does it have
to be bu with other
brands the locations where do we going
to go pick up this product is it in
Northeast
uh that's going to impact the final cost
of the product right because if we have
to ship this to Asia it has to travel
throughout the us and we have to know
those data points anti in
anticipation is the product standard can
it be custom made that's also something
that we have to look at because it's
actually a financial there's a financial
aspect behind it and of course to what
extent where is the price uh point that
this product is compared to the
competition right when we look at demand
it's pretty much similar as to how big
who are the supermarkets that actually
are looking for these products right
where are they located we have to map
their needs we have to know in
anticipation or we go after them to know
in anticip anticipation what type of
products are they looking we only
focusing on retail packed Goods that's
all we focusing on um but it could be
frozen dry refrigerated and all of those
have different way is that you can
handle them so all those data points
regarding uh where we're going to
deliver this a supermarket chain may
have one store as we just as I just give
you the example here a 100 stores versus
one single store as we are working and
putting the infrastructure to deliver
this products from a factory to a shelf
we need to know ahead of time who's
buying it right so we can anticipate the
final cost of the product so those are
all data sets that we are collecting
cting at the same time when do we got to
deliver the product and the um the
preference of in terms of delivery
method air freight costs a lot more than
SE Freight uh and and and of course than
uh Road Freight can you ship Road from
here to Congo you cannot right those so
those are all the uh uh the data points
that we have to calculate and of course
what how much are they looking to pay
for the
product and then we work with Logistics
partners because we do not own the
logistics
infrastructure we we we work with the
domestic and international logistic
partners that already have a whole array
an infrastructure warehouses spread in
different addresses that we also have to
map out if we have to consolidate
products uh from uh different regions
where is the most efficient point that
we C we got to bring the product to to
make the product not only um not impact
much on a cost contain maintain the uh
the viability of the product so those
are all the pieces of information that
we have to pick up from these uh uh even
from the logistic side of the business
how big how fast of a service can we get
from them what is the cost of it in
terms of U uh moving one pallet in to
one pet out what are the routes that
they are going to offer us so we have to
uh anticipate who will be our pre
preferred partner for Asia versus Africa
versus Europe we have to in real time uh
uh decide that based on who's actually
ordering the product and where the where
the product is coming from to where it
needs to go so it's all a matter of
putting those data sets together at the
other at the other side is one other
aspect that we have to also manage is we
got to get paid everything funnels
through us are we selling this in
multiple in single currency right now
yes we are to minimize what we have to
worry about in terms of uh the the
the the
fluctuations of not only the currency
but also the minimizing in the risk of
um uh not getting paid that's another
thing that we have to also mitigate so
what we are putting in our system it's
all those data points so we can put
together a a Commerce solution that at
the end of the day will allow anybody or
a supermarket that is buying products
regardless of location to uh uh buy the
product
and wait for the product to get to to be
delivered by US based on all the data
sets that we're putting in place we have
to look at we have to look at Customs as
well
tariffs milk as we are shipping milk
from the US to um Angola Angola
charges 10% tariffs per milk if it's
going next door let's say to South
Africa they charge
25% hypothetically so we need to know
those data sets in anticipation as we
are uh showing to the South African uh
Supermarket how much the product is
going to cost to them lend it
so and we love data right again I I'm
still working on understanding some of
it but we love data because with data
with all these data sets that we
collected in anticipation we are able to
identify we work to identify Trends we
work to identify we work to at some
point with supermarket chain so we can
get point of sale data and predict
demand ahead of time um the other thing
that we certainly want to focus on is
matching better matching product and
demand based on proximity if anything
right uh and at the end of the day we
are here to do is to work to streamline
Logistics meaning we with the routes
that we get ahead of time with the
pricing that we collect ahead of time we
know what is well we hope that the
system will know what is the best way to
ship what is the most efficient way to
ship strawberries from plank City to um
the UAE to Dubai versus and and and
making sure that the product also gets
there on time and cost effectively
versus shipping the same strawberry in
real time to uh
Venezuela right so that is all that we
are putting in place with that with all
those data sets and once the once the
system is fully in uh op well
operational what we are saying is that
um at that point uh once we conquer the
food and beverage industry repeat and
into other Industries and from there of
course uh we'll see what's uh what else
comes after that
but my everyday with data that's my
everyday interaction with data uh and
that's the system that we are working on
based on the um the uh the data sets
that uh we collect every single day
thank you
guys